[Música]
antes de la Cumbre de la otan el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
se reúnen Londres con el Primer Ministro
Richi sunak y el Rey Carlos III por
primera vez desde su coronación
con altos índices de popularidad y más
de un año de régimen de excepción el
presidente de El Salvador nayib bukele
oficializa su candidatura a los comicios
de 2024 justo después de los juegos
centroamericanos y del Caribe
Uruguay intenta convertir la búsqueda de
oro en un atractivo turístico para
revivir este sector económico según el
gobierno de Montevideo en el primer
trimestre de 2023 llegaron al país un
11% más de turistas que en 2019
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
dedicada a las noticias más destacadas
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarlos
Y empezamos en Reino Unido porque el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
está en el país donde tiene cita con el
Primer Ministro Richie sunak y el Rey
Carlos III una primera parada antes de
dirigirse a la Cumbre de la otan en
vilna y allí uno de los temas centrales
será como mantener el apoyo a Ucrania
sin que kiev entre en la alianza Manuela
Cano con los detalles
ya aterrizó en Londres la primera parada
de una visita por Europa que durará
cuatro días vaiden cumplirá con un
pendiente dialogar con el Rey Carlos III
sobre medio ambiente la reunión se dará
después del encuentro con el Primer
Ministro británico
celebrado entre los mandatarios esta se
da Poco después de que Estados Unidos
anunciara el envío de municiones de
racimo a Ucrania una decisión que divide
a los miembros de la otan y que podría
estar en la agenda
Reino Unido destinatario de una
convención que prohíbe la producción o
el uso de municiones de racimo y
desalienta su uso continuaremos haciendo
nuestra parte Para apoyar a Ucrania
contra la invasión ilegal y no provocada
de Rusia
luego biden pasará dos días en la
capital de lituania escenario de la
Cumbre anual de la otan la posición de
la alianza transnacional sobre Ucrania
sigue sin resolverse
en una entrevista exclusiva a CNN biden
afirmó que era muy pronto para que
Ucrania entrara a la otan y que la
invasión de Rusia debe terminar antes de
que kiev pueda unirse a la alianza una
declaración que contrasta con el
objetivo del presidente ucraniano
creo que no hay suficiente unidad en
esta área y esto es una amenaza para la
fuerza de la alianza solo estamos
esperando resultados positivos O al
menos un paso en dirección correcta el
viaje culminará en Finlandia el último
país en unirse a la otan la visita será
radicalmente diferente a la última de un
mandatario estadounidense en helsinki
Entonces el expresidente Donald Trump
llevó a cabo una conferencia de prensa
con Vladimir Putin
y desde utagua despegó el primer
ministro canadiense Justin troudó en
dirección también a lituania para
asistir a la Cumbre de la otan el
gobierno de trudea es un firme defensor
del apoyo a Ucrania pero se declaró en
contra del uso de bombas de racimo un
armamento que Washington ha prometido a
kiev y que está prohibido por el tratado
de oslo un acuerdo internacional firmado
por Canadá entre un centenar de países
Pero no por Estados Unidos ni Ucrania ni
Rusia
pasamos al Salvador porque la agencia
associates acusó a nayib bukele de
utilizar los juegos centroamericanos y
del caribe para ocultar las críticas a
su gestión y es que bukele no solo
cuestionado por sus métodos en la
llamada guerra contra las pandillas sino
también por cómo ha allanado el camino
en las instituciones para que permitan
su reelección para analizar el tema
contamos ahora con Eduardo Escobar Él es
director de la ong acción ciudadana
Eduardo Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en France 24 les saludo
desde nuestros estudios en Bogotá y le
preguntó qué opina de esta acusación de
Sport washing por llamarlo así contra
bukele
gracias por la invitación Sí en primer
lugar habría que decir que los juegos
centroamericanos se dieron Precisamente
en un contexto político particular en El
Salvador porque estamos en un proceso de
reelección del presidente de la
república Pese a que está prohibido por
la Constitución hay también
señalamientos de corrupción en el
gobierno y también esto viene digamos a
engranecer el ambiente político y que
con los juegos centroamericanos de
alguna manera la opinión pública cambió
el enfoque y estaba más preocupado por
los juegos Porque si se terminaba el
estadio si se terminaban las obras que
por estos temas políticos y Eduardo en
este artículo de ap en el que si no me
no me equivoco lo citan también a usted
se menciona que la Italia de Mussolini
hospedó la Copa del mundial y que
también la Alemania nazi os pidió unos
juegos olímpicos
bukele se ha burlado en su Twitter de
esta comparación con Hitler y con
Mussolini Qué opina usted de estos
paralelismos
siempre en un gobierno autoritario este
tipo de eventos vienen digamos a
reforzar ante la opinión pública
al gobierno al presidente o sea le viene
lo viene apalancar y más ahora que vamos
a una elección en un par de meses en El
Salvador donde este tipo de digamos de
apoyo de evento de espectáculo le suma
al gobierno Porque también se anunció
por parte del presidente que se iba a
hacer sede de Miss Universo
recientemente
han se han dado bastantes conciertos de
estrellas a nivel internacional entonces
todo esto lo aprovecha el gobierno para
decir de que miren en El Salvador no hay
dictadura hay libertades y somos el país
más seguro del mundo pero hay un
trasfondo de eso o sea no es así en
realidad el asunto y le preguntó Eduardo
precisamente por Cómo se vive esta
polémica de la reelección de bukele que
usted dijo está prohibida por la
Constitución mientras el mandatario
tiene unos índices de popularidad tan
altos dentro del país
claro ahí Creo que hay que separar dos
aspectos si bien Él tiene una
popularidad alta pero por Constitución
tiene prohibido la reelección o sea
Buscar de nuevo un segundo mandato eso
está prohibido y ellos lo sabían De
hecho hay una cantidad de videos tanto
del presidente como del vicepresidente
señalando de que no se puede reelegir el
presidente pero pese a eso y aquí sí hay
que hay que señalarlo ellos van a
aprovechar el desconocimiento ciudadano
de la Constitución porque hay un 70% de
la ciudadanía en varias encuestas que
dice que desconoce lo que establece la
Constitución en términos de reelección y
la desinformación del gobierno o sea el
gobierno ha creado una narrativa a decir
la gente si usted lo quiere se puede y
no importa lo que diga la Constitución
entonces hay digamos una mezcla de que
de desinformación de desconocimiento
ciudadano que aprovecha el gobierno para
digamos decir que su candidatura es
legítima eso es lo que sucede Eduardo
pues Lamentablemente se nos acaba el
tiempo para continuar analizando el
panorama en El Salvador pero seguro
tendremos ocasión de volver a conversar
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros saludos
pasamos a Argentina porque ahí el
presidente Alberto Fernández y la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner posaron junto al ministro de
economía Sergio massa el candidato
recordemos Al que apoyan para
representar al peronismo en las
elecciones de este año el escenario de
la foto fue la inauguración del
gasoducto Néstor que va desde el
yacimiento de vaca muerta hasta Buenos
Aires
cerramos en Uruguay porque la región de
la Ribera en la frontera con Brasil
revivió la tradicional búsqueda de oro
para convertirla en un atractivo
turístico más Romero salas nos cuenta
más
la fiebre del Oro vuelve a Uruguay esta
vez de la mano del turismo en la
provincia de ribera se pone de moda a
buscar este metal precioso como
diversión tal y como lo hicieron
centenares de personas en el siglo XIX y
XX podemos ir y jugar un poco buscando
oro nosotros mismos con un garimpeiro
con un Buscador de oro artesanal y
también podemos meternos
abajo de la tierra en las Galerías
subterráneas antiguas y de verdad darnos
cuenta lo que era trabajar ahí adentro y
lo duro que tiene que haber sido la vida
para los mineros en aquel momento los
habitantes de esta región fronteriza con
Brasil quieren demostrar que son más que
una zona Ganadera y que la provincia
encierra la historia de la
industrialización del Uruguay
empieza a poblar de Aventureros de gente
que que no tiene nada para perder en el
lugar que está y decide probar suerte y
hacerse rico que después no todos lo
logran no pero la esperanza lo tienen
todos hoy en día los Aventureros son los
turistas que cada vez son más
encajado entre los gigantes turísticos
latinoamericanos de Argentina y Brasil
Uruguay suele pasar desapercibido pero
como en la ruta del Oro Busca
reinventarse según cifras
gubernamentales solo en el primer
trimestre de 2023 llegaron al país a más
de un millón de visitantes un 11% más
que en 2019 antes de la pandemia
hasta que las noticias gracias por su
atención
[Música]